[Música]
un momento que la cuarentena termino y
después de varios meses encerrados se
encuentran solos en una playa desierta
sienten el calor del sol en la cara la
brisa fresca del mar
mueve las hojas de algunas palmeras
cercanas las olas rompen rítmicamente en
la arena cierran los ojos para absorber
mejor las sensaciones de ese momento y
siguen caminando descalzos en la arena
hasta que sienten un repentino y súbito
dolor subir del dedo meñique del pie
derecho
abre los ojos rápidamente y mientras
intentan contener las lágrimas y las
palabras
y miran hacia abajo y encuentran
semienterrado un elemento metálico se
agacha para ver de qué se trata y al
intentar limpiarlo aparece de forma
abrupta en frente de ustedes un genio
es un genio diferente pareciera que paso
por una cuarentena bastante larga y es
un genio que también pareciera haber
sufrido alguna crisis les ofrece
concederle un deseo pero solo uno y en
realidad del menú de opciones que tenía
sólo le quedan dos las opciones son la
resolución de los problemas del mundo o
felicidad plena
después de lamentarse por algunos
momentos los tiempos que vivimos y que
los genios ya no son lo que eran
decidimos enfocarnos en las alternativas
que tenemos después de todo es mejor que
nada si me permiten déjenme hablarles un
poco ayudándolos en esta decisión
difícil sobre algunos de los problemas
que el mundo enfrenta hoy y sus
tendencias en el año 2015
193 líderes mundiales se reunieron para
acordar un conjunto ambicioso de
objetivos globales estos objetivos
buscaban terminar con la pobreza
combatir la desigualdad reducir el
cambio climático entre varios otros
objetivos esto sería equivalente tal vez
a esas resoluciones que muchos de
nosotros nos planteamos cada año nuevo
que puede ser leer tres libros o bajar
cinco kilos o tal vez mudarnos más lejos
de los sueños
el mundo se planteó 17 objetivos y estos
17 objetivos se desagregan en 169 metas
y 232 indicadores a lo largo de 15 años
tal vez de esta información ya podemos
sacar algunas conclusiones iniciales la
primera claramente es que el mundo
tiene bastantes problemas no son pocos
la segunda podría ser que los problemas
del mundo no se resuelven de una manera
rápida de hecho de estos 15 años que nos
propusimos ya han pasado 5 comenzamos en
el 2015 y vamos hasta el 2030
y algunos estudios han tratado de
evaluar nuestro progreso hacia estos
objetivos y a la velocidad a la que
venimos estos estudios determinan que
podríamos alcanzar los objetivos para el
2000 94 esto sería el equivalente en
términos de aquella resolución personal
de la que hablábamos que esos 5 kilos
que se propusieron bajar los van a
conseguir bajar en el 2026 y en realidad
[Música]
esto sin contar claramente con todo lo
que han comido en la pandemia ahora
veamos algunos de estos objetivos más de
cerca empecemos tal vez con el objetivo
número 6 que es agua limpia y
saneamiento a datos del 2019 previos a
la pandemia el 29 por ciento de la
población mundial no tenía agua potable
y el 55 por ciento de la población
mundial no tenía un sana saneamiento
seguro esto significa el más de la mitad
de la población del mundo no tiene un
baño digno donde hacer sus necesidades
esto claramente son números demasiado
altos sin embargo hemos hecho grandes
progresos en este objetivo en el año
2000 el porcentaje de personas que
vivían sin agua potable era del 39 por
ciento y el porcentaje de personas que
no tenían condiciones sanitarias mínimas
era del 72%
ahora el agua potable y las condiciones
sanitarias no son solamente importantes
para la salud de las personas en
realidad ellos influyen en una serie de
otros objetivos que son parte de esta
lista de 17 como seguridad alimentaria
reducción de la pobreza preservación del
medio ambiente e incluso educación está
tal vez es otra de las características
importantes de los problemas del mundo
ellos son interdependientes el no
conseguir progresar en alguno de estos
problemas condiciona nuestro progreso
del norte déjenme tal vez compartir
información sobre un otro problema que
tal vez conozcan un poco más el hambre
el objetivo número 2 que nos propusimos
proponía llegar al hambre cero en el
2030 estamos bastante lejos de lograr
este objetivo y de hecho lamentablemente
hemos retrocedido en los últimos años en
la consecución de este objeto
a datos del 2019 casi el 26 por ciento
de la población mundial pasaba
situaciones de hambre
la pandemia del cob y agravará en este
año 2020 claramente esta situación que a
su vez
es afectada por una serie de otros
eventos como conflictos cambio climático
e incluso plaga de langosta que hemos
tenido recientemente
quisiera también hablarles del objetivo
número uno tal vez uno de los más
emblemáticos de esta lista de 17
este objetivo planteaba llegar al fin de
la pobreza para el 2030 y si bien no
hemos alcanzado ese objetivo todavía y
estamos probablemente un poco lejos de
alcanzarlo los datos al 2019 indican que
la proporción de la población mundial
que está debajo de la línea de la
pobreza es del 82 por ciento
hace 30 años que venimos logrando
reducciones en este índice y en el año
2009 90 este índice era de 36 por 136 de
la población mundial vivía debajo de la
línea de la pobreza esto obviamente
también se verá muy afectado por la
pandemia del cob y en el año 2020 que
quebrara de alguna manera esta secuencia
de 30 años ininterrumpidos hasta ahora
en lograr esta reducción de este
objetivo
ese es el impacto que los desastres
tienen en el desarrollo no
necesariamente tiene que ser una gran
pandemia puede ser un conflicto puede
ser una sequía un huracán puede ser un
terremoto todos ellos tienen la
capacidad de erosionar los progresos que
hayamos hecho en el desarrollo y
hacernos retroceder varios casilleros
que se preguntaran entonces bueno y
cuáles son las tendencias en los
desastres
los desastres en las últimas dos décadas
han aumentado tanto en frecuencia cuanto
a la intensidad hemos visto casi un 75
por ciento más de eventos acontecer en
los últimos 20 años que en los otros 20
años anteriores y esto especialmente en
cuestiones relacionadas al clima pero
también vemos aumentar el número de
personas que son desplazadas de manera
forzosa cada año ya sea por conflictos o
crisis creadas por el hombre
la lista de los objetivos de desarrollo
sostenible incluye otros grandes
desafíos de los que no hemos hablado
aquí en tanto detalle desafíos como la
reducción del cambio climático la
preservación del medio ambiente la
reducción de desigualdades la promoción
de la justicia entre tantos otros en
algunos de ellos hemos logrado avances
en otros no tanto y en algunos hasta
hemos retrocedido
en algún momento martin luther king dijo
que es subir el primer peldaño incluso
cuando no vemos la escalera en la
mayoría de estos problemas grandes y
complejos que tiene el mundo solo
podemos ver los primeros escalones pero
no podemos darnos el lujo de no avanzar
y no podemos darnos el lujo por sobre
todas las cosas de perder la fe
ahora que sabemos algo más sobre los
problemas del mundo déjenme tal vez
compartir también alguna información
sobre la segunda alternativa de elección
que tenemos los psicólogos han estado
las últimas décadas muy ocupados
estudiando nuestra felicidad o como los
llaman ellos bienestar subjetivo y han
encontrado que hay básicamente tres
grandes factores que determinan nuestra
felicidad uno de ellos es la genética
nacemos con cierta orientación a ver el
vaso más lleno o más vacío pero eso nos
condiciona completamente nuestra
felicidad existen otros elementos uno de
ellos son las circunstancias las
circunstancias de la vida claramente nos
marcan o determinan un mayor nivel de
felicidad o un menor nivel de felicidad
dependiendo la circunstancia que estemos
viviendo
hay un tercer elemento que los
científicos se han preocupado en
estudiar aún en más detalle qué
determina o nos ayuda a aumentar nuestra
felicidad y esas son actitudes que
adoptamos o actividades que realizamos
estas actividades o estas actitudes
pueden incluir por ejemplo hacer
ejercicio ser agradecido practicar
nuestra religión o meditar o incluso
invertir tiempo en nuestras relaciones
sociales todo eso nos trae un mayor una
mayor felicidad pero no solamente nos
trae una mayor felicidad en el momento
en el que estamos realizando esas
actividades sino que practicadas
regularmente pueden elevar nuestros
niveles de bienestar o nuestra felicidad
de manera permanente
entre esa lista de actividades que los
que los investigadores han encontrado
está también el realizar acciones de
servicio para otras personas y estas
acciones de servicio pueden ser con
nuestros familiares con amigos o con
completos desconocidos funcionan tanto
hagamos pequeños actos de bondad o
hagamos grandes actos de servicio
también funcionan y este es un detalle
importante en función del esfuerzo que
le le entreguemos entonces en la medida
que dediquemos más esfuerzo a realizar
estas actividades mayor será el
beneficio para nuestra felicidad
ahora si esto es así si los científicos
están correctos y de alguna manera
nosotros podemos influir en nuestro
nivel de felicidad tal vez la decisión
que teníamos que tomar inicialmente con
este genio no sea tan difícil como
inicialmente parecía tal vez no
necesitemos encontrar una lámpara mágica
y un genio que nos conceda un deseo tal
vez simplemente decidiendo dedicarnos a
ayudar a las personas que tenemos a
nuestro alrededor
podamos materializar ambos deseos al
mismo tiempo podamos estar contribuyendo
de alguna manera a resolverlo resolver
los problemas complejos del mundo pero
al mismo tiempo estaremos haciendo de
nosotros mismos personas más felices
todos ustedes han escuchado de las
consecuencias negativas que la pandemia
del comida ha traído a nuestras vidas
consecuencias en la salud en la economía
en el empleo en la educación incluso en
la violencia doméstica y tantos otros
pero existen también consecuencias
positivas de la pandemia de las que
probablemente hayamos escuchado hablar
menos recientemente una empresa
consultora impuesto a 18.000 jóvenes
antes de la pandemia y después de la
pandemia sobre cuestiones de trabajo
sociedad y el mundo en general
y encontraron el siguiente hallazgo
cerca del 75% de esos jóvenes
encuestados dijeron que la pandemia los
hizo más solidarios
hacia las necesidades las otras personas
y que tomarán medidas en el futuro para
convertirse en un impacto positivo en
sus comunidades el mismo informe cerraba
con la siguiente frase los jóvenes han
visto lo rápido que puede sanar el medio
ambiente lo rápido que pueden adaptarse
las empresas y lo ingeniosas y
solidarias que pueden ser las personas
saben que una sociedad o pandemia puede
ser mejor que la anterior y son lo
suficientemente tenaces para hacerla
realidad
hoy quiero desafiarlos a sumarnos a esta
resolución a involucrarnos en el
servicio a los demás como si nuestra
propia felicidad dependiera de eso
quiero desafiarlos a que decidan ver
esta crisis y cualquier otra que pueda
venir como una oportunidad no de volver
aún mejor un normal
a un nuevo normal sino en realidad como
una oportunidad de construir un normal
mejor para todos muchas gracias
[Música]